hello and welcome turns video playing
arc Quincy yano arm where come on let's
have some Sicilian game Ian probably
just his name does it have a text in
their own what do we do now I'm going
for exactly five check I feel that this
is something that I can play even with
the knowing very little theory okay
castles was he going for that modern
stuff there that two polymers plate no
it doesn't seem like an the case i'm
happy with classical development here
not doing anything fancy maybe you five
wasn't okay h3 was a little bit quick
quickly played yeah attacking that pawn
chain should be it should be okay very
often this kind of this kind of position
can lead to positions typical of the
reuleaux pass black place not now sp5
hangs but black plays a five at some
point and term i closed it it looks a
lot like like a room okay interesting
mmm what's now I think me this is an
idea putting a night over to see for now
you know get them mmm position that now
is looking a lot like it but no knee and
this is at least something that I feel a
little bit more at holman from the white
side will be eight okay
hmm not quite sure why is going with
this with Ruby eight I can cover that
and some way to open the B file for him
hmm yeah I'm sure but I often don't see
ideas in the Benoni for black it's just
that this is not my kind of position
from them from the black site i always
feel like white hat white should be in
decent decent shape or good shape decent
is a bit a bit mild yeah what about this
there should be two we will take them so
i have to probably take um use this rope
to cover when i'm going to play night
0.85 very likely and i am going with 85
just like that prevent any night be
sixes yeah he tries to play night c7 now
97 but then i'm going to see form and
that's the end of any active plans for
for black so how to start that's
probably for later see for Bishop b2
that's the best setup now both nights
look bad now that's an interesting one
he tries to after the capture play with
96 interesting yeah that's interesting
yeah how to do that I can't keep it
close I can take I think I'll keep it
closed but for the reason that I'm f5 is
quite unlikely to happen he wants to go
night f9 h 5 I guess my okay that's not
not a huge problem not sure if night
everyone is right down and this is
actually interesting to look at the c5
pawn
Knight takes e5 is my idea yeah he
covered dad I wonder if he still yeah he
stood out for that
you're an idea for all that kind of
forgot about totally totally forgot
about the move ok I have to have to
check that get rid of the pin yeah I
wonder if I taking us not it's not
completely weird it's got promise with
the c5 pawn take on c5 I mean it's it's
not completely completely bonkers I
don't know let's let's ask him if he
wants a draw and now ok that was to be
expected five so ok this is not the kind
of position to be a to hesitate there
was my idea I have not calculated this
in any any technique shape or form but
playing it's slowly isn't a good idea
with this kind of with this kind of
clash in the center some but I think it
looks good right the night is hanging c5
is hanging d6 is a threat so I'll i get
some some stuff here some material
LSD six huh I think I'll to go for that
right boys Bishop c5 stronger now okay
let's let's take the material
take that
yeah putting pressure on that time
whining horn hmm 92 I cannot play take
f5 this eve for okay so let's go back
again I'll get out of the fork
and maybe I should have gone back that
night doesn't have many squares if
there's Knight f6 coming I wasn't okay
no I wanted wanted actually to check go
to be eight check check no it looks nice
but still with this time can always
screw up stuff going for mates check
check check unbelievable stuff check how
lucky can you be mr. Quint iano have
come on this is a joke right reasons I
stumbled into this stuff what happened I
could have played on time but I never
like to like to do that yeah this is
just this is a completely completely
lost position but how do I win 98 wins
or whatever yeah also here yeah it's a
bit bad because he was yeah but what can
I say he was just pretty much crushed
them you know and this is just strong
computer also gives me a flat-out win so
my my video was correct them yeah rook
t1 is also resins and so on yeah this
also wins of course but she was it was
not helping
that java game and continued i can also
take a six this is this is good enough
actually it is good enough just have to
have to do something like that check hmm
yeah it was funny and it has stumbled
into that him ook ook see one ya amazing
i can so something like this is so
better for white but not winning of
course any more challenge check yeah
auntie em it just works like clockwork
yeah he gets he gets there yeah he also
had this move he didn't see that happen
in higher no time this is some chat even
easier yeah okay that was pretty awful
yeah yeah i think black was actually
pretty much old played in this game only
if I stumble at the end yeah here why
does always somewhat better and yeah 95
was very nice yeah I should have caught
me I can avoid the draw with this with
night BTW to or something like that I
just wanted to ask him what he what he
does and okay a five should lose shame
then stumbled into that the bloody
tactic at the end after after this very
very clear game beforehand twin takes a
six we can also play now okay that
wasn't great thanks for watching